on North Las Vegas family speaking out
about the nightmare they survive when
their house was destroyed by fire
happened last month near North 5th
Street and the 215. the colemans tell
Christian
their family including their two dogs
managed to escape safely because of
something they recently installed
fire went up in the walls over and back
down on that side three weeks after a
fire destroyed her home Charisse Coleman
can't wrap her head around the new
reality her family is living there's a
point of time I panicked leaving the
home walking out of the house or walking
out of my bedroom my mom yelling
frantically and I asked where the
children are once she said my daughter
Ryan was in the shower that's when I
kind of panicked Coleman says all six
family members and their two dogs
escaped the fire I'm glad you just got
out of the shower but the aftermath they
say was a nightmare thousands of dollars
in Damages and items with sentimental
value all gone there's literally
according to the north Las Vegas fire
department on September 23rd Flames were
reported in the home's Garage on
Jacksboro Court around 10 pm the Red
Cross disaster action team of volunteers
also stepping in to help and quickly
learning the smoke detectors they've
recently provided had saved the family's
life had they not had the smoke
detectors to learn to alert them their
daughter could have possibly been
trapped in that bathroom
and the family in the back of the house
the smoke inhalation is always a huge
problem those smoke detectors were part
of the organization's Sound the Alarm
campaign installed a few years back free
of charge and now saving the colemans
from an enormous amount of pain it's
heartbreaking it's heartbreaking to know
that everything you worked for is gone
in a moment's time